here I think we're back right I just
went to use the rest while the internet
was down for a second uh are you still
here man
cuz we can take a look at this for
sure we'll see whether the bit rate is
stable I hope it is stupid
Xfinity ah I killed all the stream stuff
that sucks
code is not
mine that's good
um well if the math is right the math is
the annoying part so I guess we can take
this if you want to make a binding for
this you can make a binding for it but
this is
like this is not good code like I would
not accept this code as a as a PR as
is I actually like the type of stuff
here that Noah and Nathan have written
where like it could substantially be
cleaned up sure uh like yeah the
function signatures are too long but at
least it's just like one very simple
easy to follow file I'd way way way way
rather take that any day over something
like this this is just severely
overbuilt it's not that it needs to be
single file right it's not that like I
like stuff to be single file because
there's there's no reason for a project
like this not to be single file you
know um
but the thing is you can do just as bad
in a single file if you have a million
functions that go in circles and do
nothing right that's just his back it's
mostly just like you have to like it's
kind of funny like stop trying to be
clever with the design of stuff is
really the message here right like just
stop trying to be clever just write it
in the dumbest like simplest way
possible and it'll be better
but yeah if you want to Port this for
sure cuz I think that there are some gym
environments like
a yeah there's acrobot which is a double
pendulum thing
right so you could look at this but yeah
if you want to submit like a code for
this cleaner all yeah I use that as a
reference because like
nowadays stuff is just way too overbuilt
what's this
where's
code this looks like it's a well-made
video but where's
code there's no
code
yeah I don't know like this is honestly
like double pendulum should be that
should be like a a Max 200 line file for
the whole
thing
so that should be like a Max 200 line
file for that entire
project if you want to contribute one I
will gladly take that as a PR if you
just like make like a simple double
pendulum implementation that's correct
you got to be careful with the physics
is the main thing with those um because
they can go crazy if you get the physics
a little bit wrong
yeah it's not so much that things have
to be in a file is just like there's
really no reason to have them not be for
projects that are this
small it's very nice to have them just
like everything is
self-contained I'm using the C standard
Library that's it plus
five what's your dream RL environment
that you would love to
have I
mean that I know how to actually build
and just would take a lot full scale MMO
that runs a million steps per second
like RuneScape but runs a million steps
per
second I would think
that I can make like mini versions of
these but just the amount of content and
stuff that you have to add in order to
really do something is very hard that
said I do have another environment that
is at least as complex as the Moa that
is coming out soon uh I finally got it
ported to see and started doing the
rendering on it so I actually have a
version of it that's semi playable but
uh it's going to take a bit longer I've
kind of just been doing that on the side
outside of the Stream
see it's actually so funny to me how
like over complicated stuff is I it's
like I think it's a teaching problem
honestly like it matters a lot how
you're taught and introduced to
programming when you start and like the
fact that there's all this like object
oriented design and abstraction and apis
and all this [ __ ] it just like confuses
people like the last thing that new
programmers should be doing is trying to
figure out how to organize stuff like
that right I would always always rather
if I have like a new or intermediate Dev
I would always rather have like just a
file that maybe is more complicated than
it has to be that has like no
abstraction maybe there's duplicated
code whatever right compared to like
some like poorly abstracted thing that
doesn't make any sense the way it's
designed cuz that fundamentally you have
to
rewrite let's figure out why the heck
this thing isn't working so
well this will do it
right this should be brick y a brick
idx I had to learn
Java yeah that's that's what we all did
I mean I started programming when I was
like
what 12 13 something like that I was
making little Minecraft
mods Java's God awful
it creates it not only creates bad code
it creates bad programmers it takes
years to unlearn
that which is very
sad
oop
um
so I some for some reason I still don't
think that this is correct I don't know
guys what do you
think this wall is also not colliding
correctly I assume
I'm a bit confused with these wall
positions I think that we have at least
one error with these but fine for
now um
States check if GitHub has newest I I
mean if it actually if it worked then I
doubt
it um I probably just mess something up
in the port I would
think check Collision yeah with height
that's
fine and
then ball width ball
height let me see if I uh I ported the
directions
wrong I think that's pretty likely that
I ported the directions
I told you I was going to Port it at
some point
right what are our thoughts here we
have
positions ball positions one brick
positions G than brick positions
number x minus
one
tight we've
got number x minus one 0us
minus X
okay and then this one
is oh the ball velocities are totally
wrong here
0 and
zero let's fix
these yeah so this is
one
Z
zero let's see what this does
that what goes through my paddle there's
definitely an issue with the right
wall we'll fix that but
uh yeah so let's fix the right wall
thing
it's probably just the way that I handle
the variables
frankly so explain here you have four
you have six
variables for the wall
some re some features we'll have to Port
those
then let me think about this so this is
going to
be so I see you here using left wall
uses
zero okay you do have two dimensional
indexing here
okay so this is zero and
one then this should be
two and
three and then this should be three and
four no four and
five okay here's breakout right we get
Breakout
quite hard to
play and it goes it still goes off the
screen I get this right fors
with allall positions of four
you just have self withd here
right and the rest of them are zero
did I get the math on these
wrong maybe I didn't copy the math
correctly wall
position minus 50 wall
position 50
height ball
positions zero ball position one with
height
and then we have allall position is
zero X is
zero velocity minus equal
1 and then we do top wall
Collision we do position
two
-50 with
50 position withd
height allall positions of one is equal
to zero
and
you shrink the
paddle it's
funny I didn't know that paddle
shrinking thing was a thing I should
check that on the actual Atari
game ah right here you
see this it wait is this it
how did I mess this
up
positions okay so left wall top
wall yeah then right wall down
here you can see the logic is
it yeah it
works it's very hard with the frame
skip but that's true of the original
Atari game as
well is the ball supposed to keep
getting faster and faster that how the
game
works
yes why is it like ridiculously fast
I was told
um I actually I asked my mother who had
like the actual pong console growing up
and apparently the pong like ball was
very very slow but I don't know if like
we've somehow screwed up when we used
like when we made these rappers with
Atari and the games are way easier than
we remember them but
like this is
fast True Values yeah
yeah you don't have precise control
either at all with the frame
skip so I can get
53 yeah and the paddle doesn't move very
fast
break out I resolve stuff like multiple
bricks oh very nice if you have like the
diffs or
whatever let me know so I will integrate
those
um I think I can put this online for you
to play around with and then what I can
do is we can clean this up from there
how's that sound so I'll show you the
how easy it is to put this
online and then we'll do stuff like
we'll make the puff for the ball we'll
add some fixes and we'll clean up the
code that sound good and hopefully my
internet stays
EMCC
EMA
latest Source m
now this is built for
web and now we simply
copy uh build
slash we
copy d r
build
Docker puffer
Docker quite a few ad adaptations yeah
let's uh I'm mean I'm going to be here
fixing them right I'm not leaving I'm
just putting something on so you can see
it online and then we're going to clean
up the code oh okay cool that's no big
deal so what I'll do then is can you
link me the new version cuz what I'm
going to do here for the rest of today
probably is I'm going to so I'm going to
have this online and then I'm going to
clean up the code a bunch probably
um and I can integrate any of the new
things that you have as well
I'm going to get it online for you real
quick for puffer GG
though and as soon as I figure out if I
can't figure out how to put the credits
in the HTML I'll just overlay it on top
of the game um but I need to figure out
a way to add credits to the HTML like
above because the HTML is autogen so I
have to figure out how to add credits to
the top of the
page send link in Discord
online quite a few change that's no
that's no problem I will look through
and I will make sure I copy stuff and
you will let me know if I miss anything
the code is going to be substantially
simplified like without losing any
functionality I'm just going to clean up
the data structures a bunch I'm going to
cut like probably 100 lines just off of
improving data structures and it'll be
faster as
well here just so I get this online for
you real quick
let's put this where is it yeah this
goes
here we'll YOLO it and hopefully I just
get it first try I need a
screenshot
so I'll the
okay so we do we cheese
this say cheese
breakout break
out break out did I miss
any right here
breakout so breakout yep that all
works uh and then we have to open a firm
real
quick Mount C
assets
okay and then I just have to do uh
python
gp.
server I think this
works yay so now I just go put
this online
and if we give this just a moment it'll
be live on puffer
it's going to take GitHub a second to do
that
though deployed
now there you
go
nice that's game number
four um so what we're going to do I
think for the rest of today is going to
be perhaps less exciting but a lot more
instructive because I'm going to clean
up I'm going to clean up the code for
this and we're going to just make
everything a lot faster a lot more
streamlined and a lot
simpler and then we'll see where we go
from there uh but I think this will be a
nice starting point cuz like there's a
whole bunch of stuff that's just way too
complicated at the moment which you know
I see why it was done this way it makes
sense but uh I've discovered a better
alternative in the metime this is also
very difficult with how fast the ball
moves you like literally can't even yeah
I think that there is something with
this speed here little
nutty I like games but I'm not
necessarily very good at many of them so
maybe if I you're just better at this
you could do you know you could get a
better score but
uh yeah this is the best I can do here
here 67 or
whatever try it out now it's on
puff. but from here let's clean up some
code I should also just Commit This to
the main repo real
quick pong no not pong breakout. c
breakout. h
so let me see how I'm going to do this
um
yeah so many of these things just don't
need to
be yeah many of these things just don't
need to be Malik at
all honestly like very few of these need
to be dealt with from python whatsoever
I think only
like observation action and done
maybe reward just like the API
stuff maybe
I'm trying to think about this because
like
technically I'm trying to think if you
can make this whole
thing accessible from python or
it there should be a way to do
it
um I can start off with some simple
things though for
sure we'll start with some simpler
things so this is float ball
X ball
y
float b b x b b y
uh yeah we don't care about
this so this gets deleted from the
signature
yeah there's like just way too many
stroks in
so this is like the less exciting
portion right of the dev content but um
this is probably the more instructive
portion frankly because this is where in
the
next let's see it's 251 I do have to
leave earlier today so let's say in the
next two hours here two to three hours
uh I'm going to take this in I'm going
to make this into something that's like
very clean small polished a bit faster
as well probably from the memory access
patterns uh and I'm going to see how
much I can do on that but I think it's
going to be much much nicer by the time
I'm done with
it and you'll see it's just like a
very simple disciplined process
we'll do the ball position and
velocities
first did that do it
right yeah that did it
and you'll see as well that like once
these variables become uh easier to deal
with the logic is also going to become
easier to deal
with this is did I get the uh or so I
got to be careful not to mess up any
indices because that will make my life
substantially Less Pleasant if I do them
wrong that can be tricky to
find don't need this
this
and see what a difference that makes the
readability of
it and in fact even if I did have to
have this be
vectorized um because it's C in because
you don't have Nice Slice indexing I
would probably just have separate arrays
for like ball X ball y I would still
have it that way and I'd still save an
index
saved this is VX right mess that up yep
all
X whoever came up with the idea of like
have really long and descriptive varable
names like yeah I don't abbreviate stuff
but like long variable names do make
stuff harder to
read the reason mathematicians use
individual
variables okay so this should be the
same
hopefully does this did I miss the ball
did it go through the paddle yeah
okay something is broken
here uh let's see I probably missed
something in the Collision check with
the
paddle let me just see what
uh this is why I committed it
this didn't happen before right yeah it
definitely didn't go through the paddle
somewhere possibly in check Collision no
this didn't get
modified ah this is ball
y right here this is ball
y that's probably
it I'm pretty
confident yeah so just have to be
slightly more careful when porting right
if I were being very careful I would
have done one variable at a time time
good next casualty of this is going to
be
um
paddle position right paddle
position it's going to be
float paddle X paddle y
y
pedal X pedal y
why is there even a
paddle I don't even know why there is a
paddle y honestly that's
funny I mean we can leave it like this
right
X where did I mess it did I mess
something
x correct you are thank
you does it still
work okay so that's another redundant
memory allocation fixed we add you know
an extra variable to the struct maybe
but we save a bunch of memory
Shenanigans and uh a bunch of weird
indexing we're going to continue doing
this and then they're going to be more
substantial refactors
thereafter yeah so this paddle widths
paddle Heights should just be
float paddle
WID paddle height
there should be float paddle width and
then float paddle
height
here they should have to get pasted in
here
fired
with height
skip num
agents I like just can't see where in
this function this is hold
here I'm just going to put this here for
now
did wait what does it bounce off of the
it bounced off of the that's bizar
oh it like
bounces that's so weird because it it
looks off of the X cu the x coordinate
so if it goes under the paddle it
bounces right let's figure out
why paddle height
there we go
whoa
uh so assuming the paddle Y is wrong
somehow right
n of height minus n paddle
height arcanoid seems to have simil
similar physics let me check
that H this is a little Ray breakout
that's cool
uh this seems like a very easy game
break out
hey that's what you're looking for you
play one of these
right apparently the original Atari game
actually punishes you for doing that by
making your paddle smaller
I mean this is nice but like I wonder
how cleanly the rendering is separated
from the uh the state logic
right like there's there's a difference
between trying to make something that's
like you know it's in C so it just it's
fast versus hey this thing needs to
generate ludicrous amounts of data for H
perf reinforcement learning right that's
like a whole different regime of of
performance that we're looking
at here let me just beat this thing real
quick
game
code 320 lines
yeah so you can see
here it's got the uh the render logic
mixed in with the state
logic it's also
yeah it's using globals it's using
globals as well you can see that this is
just like there are few things that are
not
designed the way you would want for uh
for
RL there are a few things that are just
not designed the way that you would want
for RL
okay this is good now let's see what
else we can get rid
of ball
oh yeah we didn't actually fix this
paddle being stupid did
we I don't know what the heck happened
to the paddle let's figure this
out I think this was the line that we
were suspicious of before I got
distracted here
height the paddle y looks
fine
uh maybe I'm passing it in wrong or
something hold on it's probably just
getting passed in wrong right with
height
here there we go so this is
fixed appears to be fixed
right yeah collisions are
okay still
works it still
works so now the question is going to be
how much stuff we want to move
um how much stuff we want to move
into technically like all of this can
just be done in C but then we're going
to lose access to most of it in uh in
the python
layer so I have to think about how we
want to do that I'm going to go use the
restro from real quick and then we're
going to keep going on this though I'll
be right
if
okay oh welcome YouTube
folks we are currently
refactoring this breakout implementation
breakout is a very simple game slight
slightly less simple when you want it to
run a million steps a second not that
much less simple but there are a couple
things to think about uh and we're
currently trying to clean this up so
that it's nice and easy to follow as
well the main thing I'm currently trying
to figure out is um
if you're if you allocate data in Python
and then pass it into C then you can
easily share back and forth which makes
it really nice for logging stuff when
you're training agents on this um but
then you end up needing extra code
because it also has to run as a
standalone and pury with no python so
you end up having a couple different
things to happen
I also I kind of like the idea of
like if I make the paddle with like a
parameter that you can pass into the
environment it'd be kind of cool to like
make the game harder over time until
like the RL agent is learning to uh to
like balance the ball on one pixel of a
paddle or something that'd be really
cool
I think we could do that as well I think
we could do
it okay maybe I'll just chill out for a
second and I'll think about
that come
on anything happening
here I run out of stuff to uh to post
R El should learn that or each hit gets
faster each hit does get faster at the
moment apparently that's how Atari works
though I think that the uh the tuning is
a little bit
off so let's let's talk about some like
since we have a few folks here let's
talk about like some interesting design
stuff with
this so technically right if I made the
whole state static if I made like the
whole thing like static
State
then
oops then I could just pass that in from
python I could like pass the memory
block in from Python and then you'd have
access to the entire state from
python I don't know whether that's
actually necessary or
not because like you really don't need
to allocate everything from
python there's technically no harm to it
if I can figure out a clean way to do
it cuz it's a startup time operation you
do it once and it's literally it's the
same code right it's like numpy
allocating a block of
do yeah that might be cool to
do just have the entire state of the
environment be
accessible how do you do
that presumably
it's a little tricky right because if
you have
pointers if you have like pointers to
arrays I know how to do it if you have
static arrays
for
sure what if you have Dynamic length
arrays which to be fair I don't
necessarily
really so let me I'm going to diagram
out what I'm thinking about so people
can see because I think it's it's useful
occasionally for me to diagram stuff but
also it's kind of
go okay
so here we'll show this um they're kind
of three layers right so there's like
Python
scyon and c and there're these like
these
boundaries so the goal of what I'm doing
here is I want you to be able to like
prototype in Python if you're
comfortable with that and then you can
easily you know
fast this is like a fast Port right and
then you can go to C for
wasum
so you can write your code and then you
can Port it to scon just add some types
to make it faster and then if you really
want to think a little bit more you can
go to C and then you can compile for web
assembly and put it online that's kind
of my goal and you know there's some
features that we want here so
usually the way that we have uh we make
this nice we want to get logs in Python
right we want to be able to get
observations and stuff in Python even if
it's being computed in C so what you
have is like observations let's use
OBS what you had do you allocate them
compute and then this is like you know
shared
meem so what this means is that you
allocate the memory in Python you pass
that block to C and then whenever c c
does any computations on this memory you
automatically have the results mirrored
in Python this is what a memory view
does in scy on but you don't need a
memory view you can just do it in
see so what I'm thinking is I'm going
one step further what if we take like
the entire
State we allocate it here we send
it you know either to C or to
scon and then we you know do
update here then I would have access to
the entire state in Python so anything
any data that I want out of see I can
have in Python for free doesn't cost me
anything that seems like a rather nice
thing and then this also lets you do
um this also lets you do stuff like
MCTS so like you know
MCTS is
free because you have State uh you have
fast ability to set State because you
have the entire State as a standalone
that's really
yeah I'm trying to think why I have not
done this
previously well I guess some of the
games have kind of large
states but for the simple games why not
right
so there are a couple little weird
things that you have to do with
this
do would I have to do everything as a
static
array because let's say like you have a
struct
instar I guess it would be over here but
like you don't know what the length of
this thing is so you don't know how to
allocate it in
Python because you don't know the length
of
it how's this work in
scon how's this work in syon CU it does
work in
scon um well what you end up having is a
memory view not an array
right so does that change
anything
uh I don't
yeah you shouldn't be able to get
um I don't think that you can get the
type of a struck that
has pointers in
it
right oh no you can but the thing thing
is then it's not contiguous memory
obviously because it's a pointer right
if you have a pointer you can't have any
pointers in your array at all because
the moment that you have a pointer it's
no longer in contiguous memory duh the
pointer is itself it's a pointer it's an
address meaning that your data is
somewhere
else yeah so you don't want so you just
can't have
pointers so you basically you need to
Define maximum sizes is uh for
everything which is very bad that's
actually very
bad uh it's bad for multi-agent
environments at the very least it's bad
for it's bad for a number of things come
to think of
so yeah that's tricky there's a there's
definitely a limitation there so the
limitation I'm discovering here is
um you can kind of choose you can either
have like variable
environments where you can do like lots
of different settings of each
environment that might have different
sizes of space uh you can or you can
have fast State resets and the only way
to get both is by having everything
padded to like a Max size of some of
some
sort which you don't like to do
generally
what makes sense to
do based on
that I guess the simplest thing is just
going to be to
um yeah let's just keep the code simple
and see we'll add a couple hooks in
Python there'll be uh a loop Some Loops
over multiple copies of the environment
in pure C so it'll still be fast enough
I think we'll go from there so we can't
quite do the full thing I wanted to do
but that's not really a big deal we
don't need to do this
yet I need to come up with more of these
silly things they do well for
uh silly Twitter
it actually what do I do I don't need
these time steps
oh this is not even saved
anywhere we don't need that at
all hit
counters we'll just call this hits
look at that the observations are almost
now
fully almost fully
it's
good and um a few more of these this
float wall
matter I don't think you need wall
positions at all
I could be wrong here but this is
literally because it zero is just
zero let's see if this still
works yeah it's like this is you don't
need a variable if you don't need a
variable right
let me make sure I can hit the right
wall just
fine what else we have
here uh brick x y and States these are
actually
reasonable episode episodic return is
just going to be float episode would
return
we might not even need this variable to
be
honest yeah we really shouldn't need
this
variable we just have to change a couple
things
up uh instar scores this is just going
to be in score
and uh this float star
reward this is actually going to be a
float star I'm pretty
sure observations actions reward and
done let's do it this order though I
think actually we're going to end up
moving these cuz the for struct
packing we'll probably end up changing
this
right yeah this implementation is going
to get like 100 lines shorter than the
original just with a few little tweaks
over two we'll have to actually go
through the logic at some point here
there a bunch of like random constants
and
such this is already nice uh this is
already fairly nice
though right width brick height ball
width ball height numb agents numb
balls and I think we can change the
um the inip function
a little bit as
well yeah we can change this function a
little bit
too cuz these states
so the reason for this is like you know
why aren't you doing all the allocations
in the allocate function well the point
of the allocate function is to let you
or the init functions to let you pass
stuff from python but you're not going
to pass the brick state from python so
this is not
wait fre see breakout and then you free
the brick states
right
free the n
free oops free see breakout like
this
good still way too much boiler plate but
we're getting
yeah we're going to have to definitely
go through the the full Logic for
this I'm just looking
initially n with
zero What's the
quite a bit of stuff in
here and then this numb
substeps I don't think we need frame
Skip and numb substeps
right we literally just need like OBS
per second or whatever and like
resolution
I'm trying to figure out
like there definitely are more
optimizations lots more optimizations to
make in here I'm kind of at a point
where I'm trying to figure out what
stuff I want to actually
do what stuff I don't need to
do why offset
well let's do let's get rid of all these
like hardcoded 50s
right why offset
50 now this is going to
y
offset
this y
offset +
50 y
offset this is y
offset oops
needed
okay game still works
right make sure let's lose the life
looks
good do I want to clean up the
signatures
yet I think not just yet cuz we're still
going to cut some stuff
out what other magic numbers do we have
in
here we don't care about the text being
hardcoded
won't care about the background color
being
[Music]
hardcoded
score what's this 620
well actually there are few numbers in
here I got to ask him about like I don't
know about this
implementation I mean you could like
make a brick struck and stuff you could
make like brick struck and stuff like
that but I really don't think it's
necessary because
like it really just has its position and
everything else is redundant or repeated
information unless you wanted to have
like bricks of different sizes I don't
think it's
needed so we have this generate brick
positions thing
fine there's so many of these
um these like variable coefficients and
such
though just like all these variables
here
I'm trying to think how many of these
you'd want to mess
these like domain
randomization but then you would want to
assign them on reset right not on a knit
or I mean like
alternatively you would just assign them
in the python binding or whatever
yeah cuz I really don't like the
um the amount of just stuff
here I don't want to just hash to find
these or pound to find these
substeps I really shouldn't be stuck
here there's still so much more to
improve but you know it's like once you
get the really easy improvements out of
the
way let me go figure what this substep
thing is real quick
I think there's a cleaner way of
implementing this as
well this like frame skip versus substep
stuff
you want like updates per second and
observations per second or something
like
that on there's got to be like more
basic stuff though to improve here there
should not be 400 lines of code
I guess like the thing that's bothering
me is the size of all this state data
here
right I guess that's sort of what's
bothering
me like why should this be bothering me
though what is it that is bothering me
here I mean I guess it's the fact that
all these variables have to get set
which means you have giant Constructors
in C
right and then in scon you're going to
have to have the same giant ass
Constructor
right and then again the same thing in
Python for all these different constants
let's say that we did want all these
things to be tweakable right
we would have to do it on
reset right that's when you initialize
all this
stuff should I use your Docker or
standard Windows Raab to prototype a
game first well you definitely shouldn't
do windows stuff um this is
WSL I'm running the docker on WSL you
can run with or without the docker uh
for rib itself the dependencies are
really easy so it shouldn't matter
puffer tank is more there because of all
the other dependencies of fancier
environments so I would just grab like
any any linuxes environment like you
know WSL is fine whatever the docker is
fine anything is fine
I'm stuck thinking about how I want this
to be uh how I want to design this so
that it'll be like I'm thinking of like
cool demos where we can like move some
sliders around and have it play a whole
bunch of different types of games of
breakout or
I should go make a shake is what I
should do I'm stuck on
this on how I want to build this so
here's what I'm going to do uh you get
that you get your Dev environment set up
for the next few
minutes I'm going to be right back I'm
going to go make a
shake take a few seconds to
reset and then and I'm going to figure
out how I want this thing to be
designed uh technically I could just
hardcode all these things and be done
with it but I think we can do a bit
better than that so I'll be right
here yeah had to make a shake I'm
allowed to leave for a couple minutes on
a stream aren't
we've got
a a friendly competition on hand with a
pi at
NYU first 2,000 total so can't be
missing the shakes
don't tell him but my uh previous sum of
best is 980 so we're pretty damn close
as is just got to retrain a little
previous sum of best was 980 but because
of training for the 50k and for
marathons I haven't done squats or dead
lifts in quite a while um that
said I've only been doing squats for
like I don't know 3 weeks again squats
and deadlifts I
did I did a squat set of 245 for8 the
other day and then I did uh three what
was
that I think
355 uh deadlift for five both pretty
comfortable so not that far off
I've hit 315 squat 405 deadlift before
but that was a couple years ago before
the
though the real kicker is the 260 bench
that makes it a lot
easier it's probably going to be like a
315 squat
425 uh deadlift and 260 bench is
probably going to be what I go
up maybe the squad will go higher we'll
see that's always been my worst lift
though it's like mechanically a very
awkward lift for me
so I think we do kind of want all of
these variables on a
net the only thing that I can see that
we could potentially improve
here would be the creation of the struct
itself
potentially is there a way to allocate
and assign um all the members of a
struct like in one
go stupid chat
jity R
do
away
uhu and also assign
variables
with = 1y =
nope you can't
I hate
this hey B how's it going
welcome we got some cool
stuff
ported they're quite
hard cuz the controls are not very
precise with the frame
rate War Games what needs fixing just
implementation no nothing it's just
improving on code and making there be
less boiler plate and
stuff they're pretty
good now that I'm looking at them
they're pretty
good I really don't like these giant
call signatures
some point I'll figure out
yeah oh
funny they're
big well that's what I'm trying to
figure
out and no that's not just C for you
that's a bunch of
languages pretty much anything without I
mean even like default arguments don't
solve this if you think about it because
you have to have the freaking defaults
on every function
then I mean Let Me Maybe This is the
time to uh to just think about it you
parameters no we're not adding
complexity to save we're not adding
complexity to remove perception of
complexity make it a
header no there like we're not going to
add like things like that in order to
say like this is perception of
complexity right like this doesn't
actually make stuff more complicated
it's just kind of
ugly so here's let me diagram this out
actually where did the sketch go so I
mean here's the issue with this right
so the issue is like there's like the C
layer right so we have in
it or
actually no here so we have we have
params okay but then like when you go to
scon you need this init
because this gets called from scon and
this also takes the
pams and then you need a binding in scon
which is like s in it or
whatever which also takes
params and then you need to freaking go
from here into
Python and then you also have to put an
init
here so you literally have 1 two three
four different places where you need to
copy this ugly header
actually it's worse because there has to
be like a uh a header
here so literally five places where you
need this stupid function if you need it
in one place I wouldn't
care or even two places if you just
needed it in in uh C once and in Python
once I wouldn't care
that's pretty obnoxious when I think
about it like why
I mean I could put the allocate no can I
put the allocate in scon no I can't cuz
the allocate needs to be called from C
I mean I can kind of cheat a little bit
if I'm okay with you having to
call and go straight from C to pyth you
can
technically but it's
worse so you can get rid of scon with
pi what is it API
sure well like you can do that right but
then if you do that look how stupid that
gets where' the sketch pad go so if you
do a
struct okay right in C this is
fine uh you still have all the same
logic cuz you have to pack and unpack
this struck but you save the headers
right but then this goes into deci on
and then you have to Define redefine the
struct so you have all that code
duplicated anyways in
scon uh and then this has to go into
like
Python and here now you either have to
come up with uh this has to be like a
memory view so this is becomes a numpy
structured array or it becomes a
dictionary and you can't just like pass
all the args in
normally right
cuz like you have to make a struct in
Python but python doesn't support
structs so you have to figure out how to
do like you know uh pi to
um Define seat python there is a
different way of doing it
can I can not have stupid newbie
tutorials
please
um so you can do this but
like this is kind of disgusting
does this get less bad if
um you need like Pi int and
I mean this is disgusting
here in my opinion here this is like
disgusting this is the worst of c and
the worst of python together
I don't know maybe somebody has a better
like API example but I'm pretty
sure yeah because it does star args star
keyword
yeah I don't like any of this stuff what
about C types
so init Andy minimally wrap with scyon
functions yeah that's what I'm at the
moment I'm using scyon as my
intermediary there no good docks on
stuff is the crazy thing uh where's
stupid
give
me few basic examples of finding basic C
functions
python python
with just using C types
it this is kind of gross the you have to
add the type information manually
here I expect it to infer the type from
the freaking types in the C code that
have already been
defined like this shouldn't have to
exist
like if it were just like this and then
this that would be great but that's not
how it works
right why do I have Define
art types they are already
defined the C code
actually yeah this is not good undefined
Behavior
I think scon is the best option it's
just annoying because the binding like
the nice thing with scyon is The Binding
files are really simple The Annoying
Thing with scon is that The Binding
files are really long that's the
obnoxious thing with scon but I think
that's probably going to be the uh the
best
thing I guess we'll just leave it like
this and we'll uh we'll just clean this
up I mean there are a few things that we
can uh improve as is I think we should
do
like uh OBS per second and updates per
second or
something Define
updates for a
oh or frame skip
maybe let me figure
what I have to figure out here is I want
to figure out how to update this in a
way that's maximally uh
frame skip is really intuitive
right I don't like that
it sub
steps because it should be one Loop
right
but if I leave it as frame skip that's
like something people understand way
better so maybe this is
fine maybe this is fine
away should just be
one
okay with height with
one okay with height with height ball with ball height for with
height ball with ball height for with
bre height Bri
here this should be num
OBS num obs
12 so there's a little bit of additional
just fluff
here right which I guess if uh if there
is additional fluff that would make this
feel weird
and also the parameters are in a really
weird order and stuff so yeah I think if
we just fix
this if we just fix this up like it'll
be a lot less weird
and you can see also this is taking up
additional like additional
uh um agent goes away this no longer
exists
Ms oh I missed I messed this
up I
see it's not uh you can't do no Ops like
this but you can compute
that so it's 2 +
2 plus num bricks times num calls plus
is that right
be
[Music]
written this is not how copies work this
is an error in uh this is a c
understanding error I'll point it out in
a
second at the bottom of the screen see
if you can spot it
there should be brick Rose brick Rose
brick HS
we're going to clean this up um
bre this is just this is
obnoxious Rose
bricks yeah redundant long variable
names also just make stuff feel Jank I
guess what was happening why I got stuck
for so long on this you know very simple
thing is like it just kind of felt janky
and I couldn't tell why cuz like I
didn't see any one big obvious thing to
fix um but there doesn't have to be one
big obvious thing right there can just
be a lot of little things that are like
variable names being off like things
being done a little unintuitively here a
little unintuitively there
okay so we
have 11 plus num
bricks
right I'll put a space here not we don't
need OB
this okay so this was the bug by the way
wasn't copying the observations
correctly
hope you don't mind if I yeah of course
did I miss
something let me see what I
missed is there a way to get the most
recent mobile
checkpoints and how good are they
currently I'm evaluating a recent
video self-supervised method open and
use
MOBA only work by passing by passively
watching videos
does it have to be videos or state work
like loc I guess it's similar because
it's
3D expert demonstrations the current
agents are not very good at all is the
problem um we need to do more sweeps and
stuff I need to probably play with the
models quite a bit um there's not a way
to get the most recent checkpoints I
mean I can send you one of them they're
not I I guess
technically there's probably in the in
the repo like just like aa. PT or
whatever you can use but they're really
like they get stuck on terrain and stuff
they're not very smart so we need to we
definitely need to train some better uh
better models I'm going to be doing that
this week as
well it's a hard environment right it's
a very hard environment
chat do you think another end would be
better easier one with similarly large
states or something let me
think I mean is there a reason you can't
just use like chess or go
I guess it's turn-based slightly
uh and think what are good
environments craft ax is
cool complained about
RB oh yeah that's pip install
RB oh actually the H file it can't just
be pip installed um I probably should
just include theh with the file but you
have to go grab rayb off of the GitHub
so yeah for the python bindings like
some of the the python bindings will
work with it you for like the newer
stuff you need to have rayb off of
GitHub we'll bundle it once we fully
package this for release but you know
while we're deving on it you just go
grab the rate the latest like uh tar
file like tar bundle from rib and you
just put it in the same directory
loky hoping to spread puffer lip
Kool-Aid I could try hey I'd very much
appreciate that and I'm trying to be
very supportive with these it's just
like you're picking out um a brand new
environment that I've made that's like a
really complicated environment that's
like it's hard to get baselines on right
so if you were just like hey I want to
get some cool baselines working on mooba
I'd say awesome that sounds like a great
research project I'll help you with it
and that'll save me a bunch of time as
well right but like you're expecting
there to be expert policies that's a bit
harder for sure that's definitely
harder um I mean you can still use
puffer lib for just about anything right
like whatever environment you use puffer
lib is going to make it
faster I could try training the
baselines that's a good idea yeah
they're fast enough that like you can
run stuff on one GPU and like pretty
much the thing to figure out at the
moment is like why they aren't learning
if it's hyper parameters or like model
size or bugs or whatever I'm very happy
to chat with you about that process and
if you're looking to learn stuff in here
I don't know what your skill level is
but if you're looking to learn things in
here like um I mean running big hyper
parameter sweeps doing Dev on the
environment side there's like lots of
stuff that can be done
here tenuous at
Best Bet what's what's broken with the
update out of the box in Dev
I thought I fixed stuff what's current
what's currently broken with the dev
install use puff for liit to free a very
true I think it's it's for grad as well
it's I mean it's not just a newbie
Library scon files don't
compile really they should compile post
error messages I'll fix it
branches dude I don't know
like I've been writing like thousands of
lines of C per week like of course a
couple things are going to slip
through first year grad 2.5 years
industry
swe very transfer it is uh honestly the
core of a lot of what I do is pure
engineering though it's not like big
Tech engineering it's a lot more
like it's lowlevel code it's writing
stuff that's fast it's very little like
design of big systems right it's a
little
different required in there too pizzas
okay well bet when you give me error
messages I will fix
them I'm allowed to play a little fast
and loose with the dev Branch but it
should usually compile at least it
should not be broken for any extended
period of time like if stuff is broken
and you should tell me and I should fix
it instantly that's how it works
good 420 lines we're
at for
this is
[Music]
I'm sure this is just way too fast
right yeah way too
fast it's because of the damn frame skip
I'm
sure so we'll leave it at this for now
but we got to make these feel better to
play
bricks I guess we just clean this up for
today is what we do we just fix this uh
clean it
up bricks
n
bricks do this
all right so I think we just fixed the
uh the order of
stuff I don't like that this DT is an
argument like this
no module named [ __ ] okay did you run
the setup.py
before you got that
once is this on a fresh install cuz if
you
updated I did modify that I modified the
way that that file was included so there
could definitely be something weird
there basically that file was being
built every time you ran the demo script
which was making it a little slower so
uh I made it compile on setup instead of
compile on run
pick
rate
1.0 F over
beid
by rate
oh wait is that
right
now
cleaner I mean we're like getting to the
point where this is actually kind of
reasonable
code let's see if this is crazy
fast no this not crazy fast at all right
we'll see if it goes through anything
but it's not going through it's just I'm
missing as all right
pip
installed built saw no apparent errors
on build
perfect that's I should not have errors
if it has errors either I've screwed
something up dramatically or uh you know
there's just been something that changed
and you got to
rebuild got quite a few people on Twitch
for once today usually they're more on
YouTube that's fun welcome twitch folks
all the stuff I'm building here is free
and open source you can play around with
these RL environments at puffer G
they're all online you can like play
them
here and watch Agents play some of
them and uh they're all on source code
is right
here so if you want to help me out for
free give the Repro a star be the puffer
CJ okay let me see then that's probably
uh that's probably my
um it complains about CJ after you've
built
that somehow the extensions aren't
getting built
this try
that see if that changes anything and
yeah send me logs otherwise I mean I
think that what's most likely is it's
probably just doing something weird with
like the way that I've added extensions
it's probably moved some paths around or
done something
weird so yeah I will fix
that but let me make sure let me make
sure you can actually use it for
now the main branch should always build
but all the cool stuff I do on dev
sometimes I play a little fast and loose
with my Dev branches
oh okay that's fine I can that one is
easy okay so there's something screwy
with the build process here let
here see if that fixes
it I'm just guessing if that doesn't fix
it I'll do I'll test properly but see if
that fixes
will fixed it yeah I
figured I mean like the code is the
thing is you got to realize like the
code is pretty damn stable like when
something breaks it's usually not like
something horrifically bad breaking it's
usually like I've just mooved something
around or change some small thing and
it's usually a very easy fix like you
should never just spend time especially
on the dev Branch you should never like
spend time like wondering like what
you're doing wrong you should just ask
me because like most of the time I'll be
able to just fix it instantly or even if
it is a problem that you have I pretty
much know every single thing you can
possibly encounter so I mean it's one of
the reasons I live stream is to make it
so much easier for users to just like
instantly get stuff
fixed name another library with that
support
right just like yeah it's probably this
I'll just push push fix without testing
it and it works
oops puffer Li comes with Lifetime well
I don't know about
lifetime hold on I'm allowed to like
take some vacations and do stuff right
though in practice I usually
sometimes I clock out
okay but yeah there's good
support I actually I haven't gotten any
like really crazy support requests yet
either
[Music]
whoy that's not good
I figure out what's wrong with
this but if you see the sample post the
sample post is pretty
funny ah there it is we just have the
wrong order
when people start asking me how to
enable no fins mode
cool well that is substantially improved
we're down to 400 lines
IO nope we don't use standard
IO um we do use standard
lib
H see
nice I should probably get this thing
bound to puffer right for
today so you guys can play with the
experiments and stuff if you
want yeah we'll do that real quick I
don't think it'll take
long all
right break out h
this is the Annoying Thing with
uh this is the obnoxious thing with uh
scon is you have to like copy [ __ ] tons
of definitions over like the nice thing
with scyon is it's really brain dead
easy like you can do this with your eyes
closed practically
but um you know it is an a bunch of
obnoxious boiler
it's kind of funny that it like there's
almost no need to make the header files
because scon Makes You remake them
anyways just adds more
places have to do
with I think I know what
happened did you run with dash dash
baseline or yeah did you run with dash
dash
Baseline take this thing
off yeah so take this off um basically
the Baseline policy the format has
changed slightly from 1.0 to the dev
Branch so like some of the Baseline
models need to be retrained so eval will
just do a random model and then you can
train your own in like a minute and then
you'll be able to just pass the path D-
eval model path you'll be able to pass
your own model and
ealot see if that
works we'll make sure you're taken care
of though I do have to yeah it should
work right it's
like you got to realize the cool thing
like yeah there are things in Puffer
that are going to break from version to
version but like it's not like the big
libraries where when something breaks
it's like some incredibly cursed thing
deep in the stack that's going to be
impossible it's like some super basic
thing where it's like oh yeah here just
do this you're good
right so it's not perfect I'm one person
but uh when stuff brakes it's generally
very very easy to
fix and I can usually tell you exactly
what it is just by looking at
this we go I'd like to get this binding
done I got to go a little earlier
today because
um what's this
allocate oops I got to go a little
earlier today CU I got to go get some
exercise
but uh hopefully we get this
done
render hopefully we get the python
binding done at least
yeah bre
out out
be in
frame
height sign Char actions
data obervations St yeah this is
height do
this
plant three
works and now in order to make this
binding this is the obnoxious little
bit uh again there's so much boiler
plate I need to find ways to improve on
this I think I did a little bit today we
found a way to get a little bit less
boiler plate
maybe it's just going to take some
work so this is side
breakout and then this is Breakout
this break
out
and
Raab
good
nice s breakout pix
here not
bad first try
build and actually what we're going to
do pong let me make sure there's no
breakout.
Pi move
pong
breakout p
I side break out
X all we need is the
signature this thingy
uh I think initially we can just
straight
up yeah let's just do
this initially
ations I think we're just good aren't we
no we're not because we need to pass we
do need to pass
parameters the obnoxious thing
yeah okay we do need to pass this data
here this is the data we
mode width is going to be 576
height how'll paddle
height ball width ball height paddle
speed
paddle what happened to where's this
paddle speed coming from is this
[ __ ] paddle width paddle
height ball width ball
height brick width
36 over number
calls and
brick kite is
12 brick
Rose for calls
width
WID
height uh pattle WID I don't know why
it's doing [ __ ]
here battle
height
want this to
go here
these where should I see
the model output
file um L ls-
LT experiments uh pipe
head do this
here try that that'll show you the
recent experiments
that was weird I don't know why it it
rebroadcasted the message from the
neural MMO YouTube that's
funny oh yeah we need frame skip don't
we four
width looks
good I like
this okay
[Music]
and num
OBS
equals
plus Row for
calls num actions is I believe it's
three believe four
take do report
interval working well yeah should
and there's no reason it shouldn't be
working unless I've messed something up
dramatically
out
oops wrong
window
um that's probably not the place you
want to delete
it but
noted there was uh there's like an
obnoxious version compatibility thing I
I literally just did this um I think on
Friday or
that where did you have to delete it
from I could see a lot of these being
weird the reset
yeah but there are lots of these right
they all have reset in them
um yeah God that's so
janky I'm going to have to think about
that
fresh sure I'll delete it from here for
now
I think that's pretty good for today
we've gotten um I think it's in a decent
enough spot
spot definitely there can be
improvements
what is the game objective of the
squared M it's to get to the
Target let me
see so your goal is to get to the blue
Target it's very simple
right there are a couple different modes
some of which are actually kind of hard
but the basic task is is very simple
it's a sanity check environment right I
write about this in the puffer Li paper
like the ocean sanity M they're designed
to um just be like a basic check to make
sure your algorithm is not completely
broken
I'll run all M's yeah there are a couple
weird things I think that like spaces
there might be one or two weird things
with so don't don't be surprised there
but for the most part they should be all
easy simple M's
I think we call it there though let me
see
536 that's pretty good
um let me think if there's anything else
I want to have done immed in the
immediate future here I think
mostly can we go check on the hold on
maybe we can go check one
thing want to see what was up with uh
our sweeps
is there a way to list all available M
names um kind of so
there isn't like a registry if that's
what you're asking we didn't want I
didn't want to add a registry cuz it's
like I've always hated the gym
registry um cuz like it causes so many
weird issues with Imports and stuff so
literally like all of the environments
are just LS puffer lib where is it LS
puffer lib SL
instance here are the names associated
with these but the names are just
aliases for the functions right you can
just directly import the functions so
like you don't have to interact with
puffer lip through a weird a weird
registry of some kind you can literally
just import these and you'll notice that
these are literally like there's no
magic right you can also just write this
code you can just call this code and
this will also
work right like here's the one I just
added for breakout it's literally an
import followed by return so you can
literally just import the environment
and create
it but yeah for the demos uh the demo
bindings right like the the make
functions are in
I'm a little bit surprised with this
sweep I'm sure something weird
happened maybe this is what we'll do
real quick can we uh load this
oh no right we have to
um we have to rerun with these
parameters don't we
I think I'm not going to be able to make
any progress here just like right now I
think it's going to take it's going to
take a bit
longer
so yeah I guess we'll spend probably
tomorrow uh I we'll see what I want to
do if I want to do the mobile or if I
want to clean Up breakout and pong a bit
more um there's still a little bit of
work to do there for sure I think I
we'll see if I leave Nathan and Noah to
play with those for a couple of days cuz
I think it would be good experience for
them so maybe I'll go back to the MOBA
for a couple days we'll see but uh
anyways I'm going to call it there I got
to go get some exercise uh I'm going to
try to catch up on some sleep as well
and then I will be back tomorrow are you
um are you set here with the uh with
puffer lib or do you have any last
questions cuz I do want to make sure
you're all set before I
leave can always help with installing
yeah Betty says it works when you uh
when you run setup.py uh build X so
there's something weird with build X
probably from a recent thing I did but
uh yeah
anyways I'm going to
go yeah I'm going to go get some
exercise I'll be back tomorrow oh um
yeah bet you can go take a look at the
pong and breakout code if you want it's
a pretty good reference at this point it
could be cleaned up a little bit but I
think Noah and Nathan should be able to
like get some stuff running from here if
they're so inclined I think it's like
200,000 steps per second training but I
have done zero optimization like zero
zero optimization it'll be like it'll
well over a million with optimized and
like you can play them online right
they're
nice so that's like two of the Atari M
two of the
classics
done working
and other ocean tests after that
interesting Ms yeah that's a good idea
yeah for
sure scyon doing stuff without python
callbacks yeah I mean I just went
straight to C because it was easier for
me to be
honest you can take a look at that when
I Dev the environments these days I just
Dev them in pure C and then I compile to
C right so I don't have to wait for all
the python Integrations and all the
scyon
stuff it takes a little bit of time but
like the good thing thing now is that
you actually have a lot of sample code
right like you have the whole pong
environment and the whole breakout
environment to see two different
projects now and how those work and
they're very very
simple so I would suggest reading
those I haven't cleaned up the pong one
fully yet but like the breakout one I
just cleaned up decently so anyways I am
going to be off now I will see you
around bye thanks everyone and uh please
be sure to Star Puffer lib on GitHub
it's all this stuff is free it's all
open source I work on it full time all I
ask is that you start the repo if you
like it helps me a ton uh I've also got
a Twitter Twitter is pure technical so
if you'd like RL stuff I post about RL
over here other than that thank you and
catch